this place is like twice my grandma
wouldn't hang out and as killer
it's finally give us these cops
my dick is bigger than this
as soon as you go to that party which
one I've never liked for I think I saw
on Facebook seems like the Saturday ders
oh yeah I went to all of them yeah all
right man look like strippers free beer
what's my ex there I know that Jared's
dating her new I mean I don't know so
high like just get tougher than the
mermaids as I thought of that word I
mean I get it you know I get why she
left me for him like musical dudes
straight dude if Jared where my
neighbors and he wanted to borrow some
butter syrup I totally live
yeah man Jared super cool like sitting
next to him in his sight so lit quiet
it's like what am I saying next to his
Fink's
what the [ __ ]
Oh Mercury's in retrograde or whatever
oh dude I like your shirt where'd you
get it it's Jared
yeah no I mean if I were like the head
of billboards in town I would definitely
put Jared you know you just see him
anything wow what an inspiration like I
wish that the Sun would shine as bright
as he does
and it's like okay I know you eat your
vegetables all the time but do you also
eat vagina everyone thinks it's hot but
really everything's implanted you know
any where's that pink shirt with that
pink Stein it's totally in right now and
I get it but it's also like okay what
are you my little pony named anyway
tells the world that it's a professional
golfer would really well yes a man I
like totally got laid last night good
job nice to pick oh and I left my phone
at Jared's house
Hey so dude I'm gonna open up my oil
change shop like a jiffy lube with tire
changes toughness dude that's awesome
and boys and wanted this man that's
awesome thanks bro you know jared is
probably looking for a job
oh my god I hate him so much and I just
wish you could fall off a cliff I don't
know if you noticed but he's starting to
get a bald spot on the back of his head
and it looks like a crater put there by
an asteroid yeah and I think it needs
all talk okay that heats health everyone
I graduated pina colada finally I got
another 9 they started just a little
bigger but whatever man
oh I think guys dumped my dick oh man I
don't think this song is gonna hold that
in Oh